- This is a Christmas song we wrote--
- For people you can't normally
share Christmas songs with.
♫ Maybe you and I
♫ Haven't seen eye to eye
♫ On many things this year
♫ We've had our share of spites
♫ Plenty of Facebook fights
♫ And I generally don't want you near
♫ But when it's holiday time
♫ And the bells start to chime
♫ And I think about what you say
♫ I force a smile on my face
♫ And a skip in my pace
♫ And wish you a Merry Christmas day
♫ Merry Christmas to all my haters
♫ Merry Christmas
♫ Though you might hate me
♫ Online berate me
♫ I hope you see Saint Nick at your tree
♫ Merry Christmas to all my haters
♫ Merry Christmas
♫ Let's have a truce
♫ Around the Christmas spruce
♫ Then we can get back
to our normal fuck yous
♫ No we're not quite
♫ The best of friends
♫ You say you hate to look at my face
♫ And most times of the year
♫ I'm glad to disappear
♫ When you and I are in the same place
♫ But when Christmas is in town
♫ I hope Santa comes 'round
♫ And turns that frown upside down
♫ I hope friends gather near
♫ And drink gingerbread beer
♫ And laugh while naming
all those reindeer
♫ merry Christmas to all my haters
♫ Merry Christmas
♫ Though you might hate me
♫ Online berate me
♫ I hope you see Saint Nick at your tree
♫ Merry Christmas to all my haters
♫ Merry Christmas
♫ Let's have a truce
♫ Around the Christmas spruce
♫ Then we can get back
to our normal fuck yous
♫ And I say this although
♫ Once it's tomorrow
♫ I know you'll make me feel really sick
♫ While I try to stay strong
♫ Se we can get along
♫ You've always been a dick
♫ Someday soon
♫ I hope you'll move to the moon
♫ And stay there the rest of your days
♫ And while normally I'd be in your face
♫ I bite my tongue and say
♫ Merry Christmas to all my haters
♫ Merry Christmas
♫ Though you might hate me
♫ Online berate me
♫ I hope you see Saint Nick at your tree
(yelling)
♫ Merry Christmas
♫ To all my haters
(yelling)
♫ Let's have a truce
♫ Around the Christmas spruce
♫ Then we can get back
to our normal fuck yous
♫ To our normal
♫ Fuck yous ♫
- Merry Christmas (speaking gibberish)
- Merry Christmas, have some fruit cake.
- [Voiceover] Please, please, come in.
- [Voiceover] Have some fruit cake.
- Please come in.
Great to see you.
- Step under the mistletoe.
- Great to see you, great to see you.
Mmhmm.
- Asshole.